The history of philosophy has been dominated
by competing arguments around the ideas of
Free Will and Determinism. Simply stated,
the issue hangs on whether human beings should
be thought of as fundamentally free to choose
their actions and mould their lives – or
whether they should be deemed as being at
heart determined by forces beyond their control,
be they fate, biology, politics or class.
The debate has been long-running and hugely
vicious. It began in Ancient Greece, was picked
up by the Romans, dominated Christian philosophy
and rumbles on to this day among philosophers,
psychologists and neuroscientists. Part of
the reason why the question seems so hard
to find a conclusive answer to is that it
is almost always framed in objective terms,
as if we might discover whether either Free
Will or Determinism could be an advisable
interpretation for human beings in general.
But, in truth, the debate becomes more interesting
and more relevant if we change the parameters
of the question – and ask simply: is an
idea of Free Will or of Determinism more or
less relevant to me? All of us will have different
needs in this area depending on our contrasting
levels of two psychological qualities: Defeatism
on the one hand, Aspiration on the other.
There are people whose levels of Defeatism
have grown so high, they too readily declare
that responsibility for things always lies
outside of themselves: the course of their
life is, they tell us, entirely determined
by parents, school, the government, the bosses,
the media… anyone but themselves. The result
is radical under-achievement and self-deceit.
But there is another kind of difficulty created
in people whose levels of Aspiration have
grown so high on the basis of overly exaggerated
notions of Free Will. They will deem that
everything about their lives is capable of
change. They will declare that they can achieve
all things simply through an exercise of the
will. Their career and income, their relationships
and prospects are all, apparently, subject
to dramatic change. It’s an inspiring philosophy,
but one that reliably also leads – when
things don’t work out, as they never do
in all areas – to bitterness and rage. Each
of us needs to decide for ourselves whether
we should have a greater faith in Determinism
or in Free Will. We should ask how much of
the suffering in our lives can be traced back
to a defeatist attitude and how much might
be traced back to reckless aspiration. Some
of us need to dial up a faith in Free Will,
others need more of a mellow acceptance of
Determinism. The oldest debate in philosophy
isn’t beyond answering. We just have to
answer it more personally, with more of a
sense of what we need to believe in to be
calmer and more fulfilled. Perhaps the wisest
way to navigate the debate between Free Will
and Determinism was worked out by the Ancient
Roman philosophers of the Stoic school. These
Stoics proposed that we should see ourselves
as always hovering between a Free and a Determined
state – and they invented a powerful image
to evoke our condition as creatures able at
times to effect great change – and yet never
far from being subject to immensely powerful
external necessities. We are, they said, like
dogs who have been tied to an unpredictable
cart. Our leash is long enough to give us
a degree of leeway, but is not long enough
ever just to allow us to wander wherever we
please. A dog will naturally hope to go wherever
it pleases, said the Stoics. But if it cannot,
then it is better for the animal to be trotting
behind the cart rather than dragged and strangled
by it. To reflect that we too are never without
a leash around our neck may help to reduce
the violence of our protest against events
which veer away from our intentions. It may
sound like a recipe for passivity, but as
the Stoics insisted, it is no less unreasonable
to accept something as necessary when it isn’t
as to rebel against something when it is.
It’s our reason that must judge the difference
and this is where we have a big advantage
over a dog. A dog will probably not at first
grasp that he is even tied to a cart, nor
understand the connection between the swerves
of the cart and the pain in his neck. So he
won’t be able to predict where the cart
is going and adjust his position accordingly.
But reason enables us to theorise with considerable
accuracy about the path of the cart or destiny,
which offers us a chance, unique among living
beings, to increase our sense of freedom by
ensuring a good slack between our desires
and what we cannot change. Reason allows us
to calculate when our wishes are in irrevocable
conflict with reality, and then bids us to
submit ourselves willingly, rather than angrily
or bitterly, to necessities. We may be powerless
to alter certain events, but we remain free
to choose our attitude towards them, and it
is in an unprotesting acceptance of what is
truly necessary that we can find a distinctive serenity and freedom.
At The School of Life
we believe in developing emotional intelligence.
To that end we've also created a whole range
of products to support that growth. Find out
more at the link on the screen now.